JD Vance in Ohio a guy that again nobody
knew was not getting into politics has a
successful career does some some VC
stuff like did not have to do this but
had just had about enough with the
Border had just had enough uh had about
enough with the fentanyl situation and
uh and then he got in and he's running
against Democrat Tim Ryan the choice for
Ohio voters is so clear you have a guy
who's been very anti-police very Pro
um very very pro-inflationary policies
and you have an alternative and I'm the
alternative and I think people are not
feeling like the state's going in the
right direction right now like the
country's going the right direction so I
think that puts us in a good position in
November it's good to be up in the polls
but at the end of the day we just have
to run our race get our message out and
I think we'll be in good shape recent
polls show this is the tight race with
JD Vance up three points in a recent
Emerson College poll my argument is
pretty simple uh the Tim Ryan that I'm
worried about is not the Tim Ryan of his
well-produced TV commercials it's the
Tim Ryan who's been in Washington for 20
years who always votes with Pelosi and
Biden and never takes an independent
vote never takes an independent stance
when the people of Ohio really need him
to now what you guys know this I mean
what does the machine do when they see
someone gaining momentum well they
always they will try to pin them into
their they're an Ultra Mega right-wing
right nationalist Christian extremist
something something something JD Vance
did not even support Donald Trump four
years ago he happened to have been on
stage in Ohio uh was it yesterday with
Donald Trump but the idea that this is
some like traditional far-right mean
conservative is just complete nonsense